vous le savez ça fait déjà un an que les
employés de sears ont perdu leur emploi
après la fermeture des magasins au
canada et leur bataille pour récupérer
au moins une partie de ce qu'on leur
doit connaît un nouveau développement
ils viennent d'obtenir la permission de
poursuivre certains des anciens
dirigeants de six heures dans l'espoir
de récupérer les millions qu'il manque
dans leur caisse de retraite
retour sur notre enquête
[Musique]
j'ai vécu ça un peu comme un tremblement
de taille juridique socom
oui un monde qui finissaient tous les
employés qui étaient là maintenant sont
démunis pour nous à ranger 2010 très
cheveux très chichement les alarmes qui
sonnait tous les indices suggérant ses
compagnes et salim pour l'instant unique
[Musique]
le couperet est tombé en janvier 2017
les derniers magasins sears ont fermé
leurs portes laissant des milliers
d'employés et de retraités en plein
désarroi quant à l'avenir de leur fonds
de retraite doit travailler pour ça on
entend des fois pas augmenter parce
qu'on ne vienne pas dans ton fonds de
pension quand on te retire moi je trouve
posthume forme de bol pendant des années
les retraités de six ont vu le déficit
de leur fonds de pension se creuser
pendant que les actionnaires de la
compagnie empoché des milliards
la mixité est alors l'argent et à la par
chambre a pris la décision de s'adresser
qu'aux 17
ils ont tout fait pour mettre leur
retraite à l'abri mais tout le monde les
a laissés tomber
qui aurait cru qu après 65 ans
d'activité le géant s'écroulerait avec
son fameux catalogue sears était
pourtant le amazon des années 70 et 80
une compagnie d'avant garde qui livrait
de tout partout
malgré sa voix un peu mécanique
l'ordinateur est toujours polis quoi
qu'on lui dise c'est alan époque où on a
travaillé la première journée le rhume
on a travaillé chez sears pendant plus
de 30 ans dont la moitié comme vice
président il a quitté en 2005 quand il a
senti le vent tourner un fonds
d'investissement américain vient de
prendre le contrôle de cibles aux états
unis et de sa filiale
sears canada à sa tête et des limpers
une star de wall street 2 fois
milliardaire
wil tous challenge dès son arrivée six
ans quand un important virage
la première mano à mano au canada
arrêtez là bas tu le quart des crédits
la carte de crédit était un lien crucial
avec nos clients
marc cohen était le patron de la bri
mois il a été pdg de sirius canada avant
la prise de contrôle par le fonds
spéculatif de crolles nos activités de
crédit était une source de revenus
importante et très profitable et poivre
la vente de la carte de crédit rapporte
2,2 milliards de dollars cs verse 1
milliard et demi à ses actionnaires
du jamais vu au lieu de réinvestir cet
argent dans la compagnie comme frais la
plupart des entreprises
il a donné aux actionnaires sous forme
de dividendes tout gérer
il est le principal accusé est reproché
avec 6 il n'a pas pris part à cette
décision
elle relève du conseil d'administration
de sears canada sur lequel il n'a dit il
aucune autorité
mais l'ex pdg marc cohen est d'avis
qu'il exerçait une certaine influence
il enseigne aujourd'hui à l'université
columbia
c'est un expert en commerce de détail
est depuis longtemps un adversaire très
critique de la gestion de ce qu'ils
souhaitent ils un pote et spiegel atx ou
r ça a été le début de démantèlement des
actifs qui a nui à l'entreprise qui a
paralysé l'entreprise et qui a fini par
tuer l'entreprise
d'un des plus grands commerces de détail
au pays
l'entreprise sera fragilisée
progressivement par des coupures sans
précédent j'ai vu le déclin par les
faits qui me disait que ça change et qui
avait pu la même marchandise la chambre
marchandise était différent
les consommateurs réagissent mal aux
changements les ventes nettes a
dégringolé
fin 2013 plutôt que d'investir pour
relancer la compagnie 6 vers un autre
important dividende d'un demi milliard
de dollars à ses actionnaires les
retraités vont les actionnaires
s'enrichir alors que leur caisse de
retraite subi les contrecoups de
l'économie et s'appauvrit on n'a pas vu
un cholet dividendes mais ne font pas
chier j'ai conclu que l'accompagner à
votre l'intention de rencontrer ses
obligations rabat les gens voyaient le
fonds de retraite affiche désormais un
déficit est considéré toujours que de
ces deux solistes lumière rouge
si votre ampleur devait faire faillite
vous attendent tous michel disait est
économiste à la retraite ce que j'aurais
dû faire c'est profiter que ça allait
encore bien pour équilibrer un peu ce
qu'elle verse aux actionnaires et ce
quelle version régime de votre viseur
est large
de 2005 à 2013 au total près de 4
milliards de dollars d'actifs sont
vendus et trois milliards et demi de
dollars sont redistribués aux
actionnaires
c'est dix fois plus que les dividendes
distribués dans la décennie précédente
tout ce qu'il faisait c'était récolté
l'argent de l'entreprise
les retraités craignent désormais le
pire que la compagnie fasse faillite et
que le déficit de la caisse de retraite
entraîne une réduction de leur
prestation pour le reste de leurs jours
il sonne l'alarmé auprès de la
commission des services financiers de
l'ontario
chez total est mérité pour nous
la compagnie régionale lioran du plan
d'action
les retraités demandent à la commission
de forcer 6 à rembourser le déficit du
fonds de retraites et de confier sa
gestion un tiers pendant que cette
bataille se joue l'actionnaire principal
et des limpers recrute un collaborateur
et ancien employé brenden strazeele
il sera le dernier président de sears
canada parce qu'on aurait pu faire les
choses autrement
c'est une question très lourd de sens et
vous le savez le croyons
[Musique]
brandon strazeele va tenter l'impossible
sauver une compagnie moribonde il est le
dernier espoir des retraités
[Musique]
hamilton en ontario
une ville qui s'est bâtie sur l'a6 comme
son père et son grand père avant lui
scott duval a passé le plus gros de
cette vie dans cette usine et le bar des
gens d'ici toutes les familles en
dépendent
[Musique]
mais cette sécurité a été menacé
plusieurs fois scott duval et les vingt
mille autres retraités de stelco au dû
se battre pour sauver leur fonds de
retraite déficitaire pour nous si tu
voles c'est notre argent personnes
devraient avoir le droit de s'en servir
pour lui combler le déficit
paul fort des millions de canadiens qui
mise sur un fonds de retraite à
prestations déterminées sont à risque et
scott duval trouve que l'histoire se
répète trop souvent dans le cas de six
le déficit est apparemment devenu
insurmontable en 2015
c'est ce qu'affirme en tout cas son
nouveau président c'était devenu
impossible de financer le fonds de
retraite et investir dans la compagnie
il aurait fallu faire dans le passé
heynckes
mais dans le passé au moment aussi où je
faisais encore des profits au lieu de
rembourser le déficit
elle a profité de mesures d'allégement
offerte par le gouvernement ontarien
tout indique que sur reverser ce que la
loi est jugée prône ainsi qu'à loi
demande à passer
le conseil d'administration doit
trancher entre des intérêts divergents
ceux des actionnaires et ceux des
retraités de la compagnie et le
certainement violé le contrat moral
entre les employés c'est parfaitement
légal et parfaitement immoral
diana kate est une analyste financière
indépendante elle aussi estime que s'il
a failli à ses devoirs et va plus loin
si son conseil d'administration sont les
premiers responsables parce qu'ils
gèrent le fonds pension ils ont une
responsabilité fiduciaire est une
obligation de diligence en vertu de la
loi canadienne robe noire inc leader
mais il n'ya pas que sears pendant deux
ans les retraités ont tenté sans relâche
de convaincre la commission des services
financiers de l'ontario de mettre le
régime de retraite à l'abri
inauguration au gouvernement notre
caillou au ministre des finances le
premier ministre dont aliot hd doubler
les lions paul j la commission avait le
pouvoir d'agir pour que le déficit du
fonds de pension soit comblé par civile
dans un courriel la commission a fourni
peu d'explications sur sa décision de ne
pas intervenir
elle s'est borné à rappeler que 6 s'est
conformé aux exigences minimales prévues
par la loi en juin 2010 est acculé au
pied du mur sérieuses se place sous la
protection de la loi dans l'espoir de se
restructurer mais quatre mois plus tard
en octobre
elle doit se résigner à tous les kids et
[Musique]
du jour au lendemain 16 mai le retraité
a pris en cas moins d'une solution
miracle leurs prestations seront amputés
de presque 20% mais il est m'énervant
les gens s'imaginent bull
mais ces quelques milliers de dollars
alors j'aurai envie de vous le dire mais
je veux pas mettre personne dans
l'embarras c'est très mineur je peux pas
faire mon épicerie d'un année avec ça le
sort des retraités de sciure relance
vieux débat
le canada est permis les derniers pays
industrialisés à considérer encore ces
retraités comme de simples créanciers
après les banques les avocats les
comptables les investisseurs même après
les gouvernements alors de pain que les
banques et les investisseurs veulent
être bien traité mais nous aussi
le gouvernement doit agir parce que les
gens sont en train de tout perdre et et
l'ex travailleur de stèles cause que
duval combier régler le problème
aujourd'hui député fédéral pour le parti
néo démocrates ils sillonnent le pays
pour promouvoir un projet de loi privé
le bloc québécois a déposé un projet
semblable
les deux demandes qu'on rembourse
d'abord les retraités en cas de
restructuration ou de faillite de saint
georges
sa place n'est pas traitée en priorité
d'autres arts de trop longues aucun
autre créancier mais sera remboursé dans
le fonds de retraite ne serait pas
complet ce n'est pas la première fois
qu'on essaie de changer le statut des
retraités dans la loi fédérale mais sans
succès déplore l'ex pdg de sears canada
highway la droite
j'aurais pensé qu'après l'effondrement
de nortel waps le gouvernement serait
devenu plus sensible nous faillite des
grandes compagnies collaborent au coeur
de cette bataille pour changer la loi
diana cac l'a mené en 2010 après la
chute de nortel le changement n'a jamais
été adopté en grande partie en raison de
l'opposition de ce qu'elle appelle
l'industrie de la faillite
trsb stephen opposition il ya eu une
opposition virulente de la part de
l'association canadienne des banquiers
de l'institut de l'insolvabilité et du
conseil les chefs d'entreprise les
banques menacent de ne plus prêter aux
entreprises en difficulté si elles ne
sont pas remboursés en premier en cas de
faillite
mais les deux experts pensent que pour
s'assurer d'être payés les banques vont
plutôt exigé des compagnies que leur
fondre
traite n'est pas de déficit l'employeur
yare pression sur lui pour qu'il le
comble au lieu de distribuer des
dividendes aux actionnaires
on aimerait mieux de se mettre l'argent
dans ton régime de retraite et nous
savoir et d'une actrice pour être plus
prête à te prêter ou à refinancer
monsieur le premier ministre je vous le
demande
allez-vous examiner ce problème mais
pour l'instant le projet de loi de scott
duval n'a toujours pas été adopté à ce
jour aucun changement législatif n'est
survenu en attendant plusieurs retraités
de stelco n'ont toujours pas de
certitude que leur fonds de retraite
sera entièrement préservés pour aider à
combler le déficit stelco s'est engagé à
vendre des centaines d'hectares de
terrains industriels des terrains
contaminés
j'aurais jamais pensé qu'il faudrait un
jour compter sur des déchets pour
financer notre fonds de retraite
on a travaillé fort pour protéger notre
avenir
ça devrait pas reposer uniquement sur
l'espoir entre temps les retraités ont
perdu non pas 20 mai 30 % de leurs
prestations
un sentiment d'injustice amin oui
l'erreur
j'ai fait tout mon possible pour sauver
la cour et s'était exceptionnellement
difficile je suis déçu de ne pas avoir
atteint deux meilleurs voilà ce que je
dirai aux retraités le principal
actionnaire et d'hellemmes peux tu nous
as écrit qu'il a toujours cru dans la
survie de la compagnie mais qu'il n'est
pas responsable des décisions prises au
canada et qu'il a directement bénéficié
d'une partie seulement des dividendes
alors est ce que monsieur laporte est un
machin est ce qu'il est un homme de
finances ou autre chose
la cour supérieure de l'ontario vient
d'autoriser une poursuite contre eddie
l'emportent et d'anciens dirigeants sur
le bien fondé d'un transfert de 500
millions en dividendes aux actionnaires
alors que la compagnie était en
difficulté
les retraités de sérieuses n'ont pas dit
leur dernier mot
[Musique]